well i mean
isn't isn't that also the story of risk
versus i mean
is that simplicity there's something
about simplicity that
uh us in this evolutionary process
is valued if it's simple it's uh
gets it spreads faster it seems like
yeah or is that not always true
that's always true yeah it could be
simple is good but too simple is bad
so why did risk win you think so far did
risk win
in the long arc of history maybe we
don't know so who who's going to win
what what's risk what's cisco who's
going to win in that space
in these instruction sets hey ice offers
going to win but
there'll be little computers that run
little programs like normal all over the
place
but but we're we're going through
another transformation so
but you think instruction sets
underneath it all will change
yeah they evolve slowly they don't
matter very much they don't matter very
much
okay i mean the limits of performance
are you know predictability of
instructions and data
i mean that's the big thing and then the
usability of it is some you know
quality of design quality of tools
availability
like right now x86 is proprietary with
intel and amd but they can change it any
way they want independently
right arm is proprietary to arm and they
won't let anybody else change it
so it's like a soul point and risk five
is open source
so anybody can change it which is super
cool
but that also might mean it gets changed
in too many random ways that there's no
common
sub subset of it that people can use do
you like open
or do you like clothes like if you were
to bet all your money on one or the
other risk five versus
no idea it's case dependent well x86
oddly enough when intel
first started developing it they
licensed it like seven people
so it was the open architecture and then
they moved faster than others and also
bought one or two of them
but there were seven different people
making x86 because at the time there was
6502 and z80s and you know 8086
and you could argue everybody thought
z80 was the better instruction set
but that was propriety proprietary to
one place
oh and the 6800 so there's like five
different four or five different
microprocessors intel went
open got the market share because people
felt like they had multiple sources from
it and then over time it narrowed down
the two players
you